[Music]
[Applause]
jay billis will be working the
college draft the nba draft coming up
tomorrow night
also wanted to talk to him about the
possibility of bubblizing the entire
ncaa tournament in indianapolis and jay
joins us now
jay let me start with the draft coming
up here is there
that true franchise
you know driven player talent-wise that
you can go
we can lock in on that guy and we can
build a round
probably not uh there are a couple
players that that i think
may fit that description one is anthony
edwards of georgia although
he's not yet a finished product uh his
decision making and defense need to
improve
but the other is james wiseman of
memphis who only played three games this
year before he got in that you know sort
of ncaa
issue and then wound up saying i've just
had enough of this
he was supposed to sit out like 12 games
after playing the first three he's like
i'm not doing this anymore just walked
so we didn't get a chance to see him but
he's still
chris he's got chris bosh type ability
except he's bigger seven one and seven
six wingspan all that stuff
but they're outside of that dan they're
a bunch of really good players
and guys that'll be starters in the
league and maybe better
but there's no there aren't any
no-brainer picks like we've had in past
drafts
have you fallen in love with somebody i
mean there are a bunch of guys i really
like
um like i really like tyrese halliburton
of iowa state
i really like isaac okoro of uh
of auburn um you know guys like that
uh onyeka kongwu of usc i like a lot
but there there's nobody like you were
asking i think initially
you know is there anybody there's nobody
like lebron or kyrie
or something where do you go okay he's
the number one pick for sure will be an
all-star
that kind of thing um but there will be
players that come out i'm positive
there'll be players that come out of
this draft
um that'll be like draymond green or
um uh you know you you name it i mean a
bunch of players that have been taken
further down in the draft that have
turned out to be great whether it's clay
thompson
uh they're a whole bunch we could we
could go down to name a 15th pick that
we were probably saying at the time well
you know it could be a starter and maybe
better but we weren't we weren't sure
the reaction to lamello ball if he's not
lamello ball and he's just another name
do we have a different reaction to him
this high in the draft
uh maybe i mean i know he drags in some
of the stuff with his dad
a little bit uh you know a little bit of
baggage there for some people
but my thing with them dan is is he's
ultra talented
as a ball handler passer um you know
he's got
positional size and length and all that
but he doesn't guard anybody and he
doesn't shoot it
and those are kind of big deals and he
hasn't finished a season in a long time
either
so he's not had a normal sort of
existence for a player that does that's
not a bad thing it's just
it's just a data point um but he's one
of those guys that you're going hey
could be
could be really good and then but could
be less than that
um like i don't think he's gonna you
know get into the league and not
not be a good player but but i think if
you're gonna go one two or three you
have some
pretty high expectations how do the ball
boys
not be able to shoot yeah that's a good
question i mean you know i know you're
you've always been a great shooter and
um
but you know there are there are guys
that can't can't shoot
and and you know lonzo's my thing has
been
why can't somebody fix their mechanics
to the point where
um you know like if the shot's not going
in
then i think you gotta you gotta fix the
mechanics like reggie miller is a
like an example of you know you you
wouldn't have
you wouldn't have taught reggie to shoot
that way you know his elbow out and all
that stuff it's not
classic form damn thing went in every
time
so you're not gonna or jamal wilkes like
nobody would have told jamal wilkes like
you need to wrap it around your head
before you shoot it
but it went in every time so you're not
messing with that
um but if it doesn't go in i think you
have to mess with it
and for those guys ball doesn't go in
enough and actually lonzo was a better
shooter than lamela
uh lamela's got a lower release it
doesn't go in
near the rate that lonzos went in but
you got liangelo
the other ball brother who all he does
is shoot
he has a great shot he has you know
great range
there it's it's just kind of baffling
that you know
the dad who was there when naismith uh
you know put up the basket the peach
basket
didn't teach his kids how to shoot you
know just a normal jump shot here
i'm amazed yeah it's not just on him i
think it's on the game
i don't know like it's almost like uh
it's almost like
shooting uh was like the golf swing used
to be years ago where he didn't mess
with it you know
that it was something that you you left
alone and
uh just more repetition and and i'll get
better
but i i do think there's a mechanics
thing to it
um but especially if it doesn't go in i
mean the best shooting coach i've ever
been around is chip england who happened
to be a teammate of mine at duke
my freshman year he was a senior and uh
just got a great way about him of
teaching
teaching shooting uh but there aren't a
lot of guys that feel comfortable out
there
teaching it and that that's unfortunate
especially the lower levels minnesota's
got the number one does minnesota keep
the number one pick
i don't know i mean there's going to be
seems like there's going to be more
trade activity in this draft but
you know you've been through this drill
more than me you know you always hear
about how many trades they're gonna be
and then there there aren't a ton on
draft day and other other
years you don't hear as much and they're
a bunch of trades
so uh you know look unless you're in
love with somebody it makes sense to
trade back but
it's it's only if you can get who you
want and then what are you gonna get
in exchange for the pick my sense is in
this year's draft if you've got the
number one pick
you you you use it um and if uh
like you know i don't know if they if
the uh
timberwolves like um anthony edwards or
james weismer lamellar ball whatever it
is but it seems like
there's a consensus that those are the
top three picks
what order they go and we'll see but but
i think i think uh
edwards is the best overall prospect
with his skill level
his body his athleticism he has the
chance to be the best player doesn't
mean he will be but he has the chance to
be
yeah i saw an interview with him
yesterday on espn and i
i really just he sounded mature he
sounded like he was ready for this
this big move we're talking to jay
billis espn college basketball analyst
what did you make of the possibility of
bubblizing
march madness in indianapolis smart move
uh i think it's the only way
in the current climate that we're facing
that we're going to get
an ncaa tournament in you know you you
have
if you're going to try to get a
tournament 13 different venues from the
the first four to the first round to the
elite eight to the final four in
indianapolis
it's not gonna work and i think danny
gavit and
the tournament committee realized that
and they decided to
to make the adjustment now so they
didn't have to make it later
uh and it's a smart move and and look i
i think a lot of people might
feel like i would jump all over this and
say see
they're pros um this is not the time for
that
they're pros anyway so this it doesn't
matter whether they play in bubbles or
not
but you'll remember at the beginning of
the pandemic when we were talking about
all this stuff that that you had a lot
of administrators saying hey
no students on campus no college sports
well they backed off that in a hurry
and and then they were saying well we we
can't have bubbles these are amateurs
they backed off that in a hurry we're
going to start the season in a bubble at
the mohegan sun
we're going to end it in as close to a
bubble as you can get
in indianapolis with the at least i
think it'll be in indianapolis that's
the the initial indication
for the ncaa tournament it's just smart
business like
basketball needs to have a season this
year
um it's really kind of an existential
issue for the ncaa that's the only
revenue they have is the ncaa tournament
if there's not a tournament the ncaa is
in trouble
uh after this season uh if we have a
tournament i think we get through this
and everything's fine
if we don't uh two years of no revenue
and and there's a a real existential
problem so i'm glad they're doing it
this way and i'm glad we're moving
toward it and oddly enough dan
right now the students going home on
almost every campus across the country
going home like this week next week
whatever it is for thanksgiving
and they're not coming back that's the
best chance we have to get a basketball
season in because the teams are going to
be essentially isolated and quarantined
on their own campus with no other
students
and that's the best chance we have yeah
i wondered if the pac-12 would have
waited till thanksgiving to start their
football season
with everybody gone and then you try to
do it like that or the big ten
you know you want to be in the final
four you want to go to a bowl game but
you do want to get the season in
pac-12 probably not going to get their
season in the big ten stumbled a little
bit here but i do agree with you once
the students go home you're basically
bubblizing your basketball team as well
let me go back to what you said about
the ncaa if they don't have
march madness over a two-year period
what do you think happens to the ncaa
well it's going to be i think there will
be a lot of change i mean you don't have
money
it's going to be hard to operate on the
same level hard to
hard to keep employees and all that
other stuff and i think they just lose
their grip
uh and college basketball gets
diminished i don't think there's any
question about that
um now is it going to go it's not going
to go away
but without the revenue i mean there are
going to be so many things
so many dominoes that fall in a negative
direction
uh i think it gets diminished and and
look i think it's going to be diminished
going forward a little bit anyway
uh but but i think it i think there's
going to be a loosening of the grip
on on college sports and the conferences
start taking over and we see some
changes that we wouldn't have
anticipated otherwise
yeah i still think that the power five
uh
is just going to grab college football
they own the they own college football
ncaa doesn't and you just secede from
the union
i don't know if you see the power five
conferences in college basketball doing
the same we do love the underdog we
embrace the underdog the underdog gets a
chance
in college football the underdog does
not
yeah i i think there's still a
reluctance to go away from the current
ncaa tournament model that's a big part
of keeping everything together
and look there are a lot of the
old-timers like us frankly
but but guys we know from back in the
day that when
in 1984 when there was the the uh
supreme court case
uh you know oklahoma board of regents
case
uh that took basically took football
away
from the ncaa the ncaa used to tell in
their infinite wisdom used to tell
schools how often they could be on
television because they thought that
they were protecting the gate like the
number of spectators that would come to
a game they thought that's where all the
money
was they didn't realize that real the
money's in television
uh so you know that's when the cfa
started the college football association
and started negotiating
uh tv contracts and all that there were
a lot of people that thought
it would have been better if if they
took football and basketball away from
the ncaa and we wouldn't have all the
the ridiculous issues that we have now
um
i don't know that i agree with that but
um but there's a real reluctance to take
basketball
to take the tournament and mess with it
because of what you mentioned sort of
the
um you know the cinderella aspect of it
i think if they took the tournament
the power five just took the tournament
and started their own tournament
they started their own tournament they
could invite whoever they wanted
but we're gonna get to a point where the
power five's only gonna play each other
they're only gonna play each other in
football
and and someday they're only gonna play
each other in basketball
because the fans have spoken they don't
wanna watch
the these early season you know home
game versus directional school
stuff they don't go to the games they
don't watch them on tv like they used to
they're not consuming in the same way
they want to watch big shots against big
shots and then we'll leave the
cinderella stuff for the tournament at
the end
would you want mark emirates job as the
head of the ncaa
i get asked that a lot because i'm so
critical of the ncaa
at times um not all the time when they
do a good job i say so
um but and i i joke about it but i i've
served on ncaa committees in the past
both when i was in college and now
i've always said that i'll help if
there's ever a chance i can really help
i'll do it
but the one thing i know is because of
my views on amateurism
i don't have to worry about ever being
asked to do anything by the end of the
day
um like even even the stuff they're
doing now with name image and likeness
like they're such ridiculous baby steps
you're going come on man
let's just do this i mean why are we
taking baby steps on this stuff
it's over you know you you have admitted
that they're pros by just
broaching the subject of name and vision
likeness let's go
and get it over with and they they won't
pull the band-aid off and just do it
were you a student-athlete at duke or an
athletic student
at duke i was i was neither
like i look at it um here's what the way
i look at it
when i was playing i was a a player and
when i was in
class i was a student and i don't i
don't think there's anything wrong with
that we don't we don't ask anybody else
what their priorities are
you know there's no other student that
you go okay now is academics your first
priority or are you here for being a
musician or are you spending more time
in the greek system or
like what are your priorities you know
it's kind of like saying are you
a broadcaster husband and father are you
a husband and father broadcaster like
what's more important to you dan like
these are questions that we only ask of
athletes
i'm a broadcaster first jay what's that
i'm a broadcaster first
yeah yeah a nominated broadcaster yes
not don't win but we get nominated
[Laughter]
jerry seinfeld had a great um great
quote about that and comedians
in cars getting coffee he said like
apparently seinfeld the number one show
uh didn't win any emmys as a show or
maybe only won one
over that run that they had and his
thing was who cares he goes
he goes the job is the award and i was
like that's pretty damn cool i should
have thought of that the job is the
award
no it's not no the job is the job
the award is the award but
but you know you have to give yourself
some credit and i give myself a lot of
credit
for acting like when somebody else wins
and we're clapping
acting like we're legitimately happy for
the winner there is an art to that
jay because every year when bob costas
would win
i had to act like um
i'm a little surprised but not that
surprised you know you go oh
oh yeah and then you know that
somebody's watching
you and then i used to start clapping
when they were opening the
the envelope like i just wanted to get
ahead of this that hey
that dan patrick's a team yeah bob costa
is one another damn
whatever sports jamming yeah it's it's
an art
it's an art it's acting is what that is
jay it is active that is interesting
and that should be an award too the the
best performance
by a loser and the winner is once again
dan patrick um have fun tomorrow night
there jay great to talk to you as always
thank you for your insights
it's never as much fun without you there
oh i know
i know but i'm not coming back to the
mothership jay
well i could come to you oh whoa uh let
me see who do i i'd have to get rid of
this would be like a james harden
situation i'd have to get rid of
probably three danettes
oh i'm worth more than three dances
thank you jay good luck tomorrow night
thank you that's jay bilas espn college
basketball and